سلسله انتصارات اوكرانيا قد تتجه الى نقطه
انعطاف اخرى
فبالرغم من استعادتها مدينه خرسم بالكامل
بعد قتال عنيف الا انها قد تضع نفسها في
مرمى النيران بسبب تعريض امدادات القرم
للخطر وفقا للمعلومات التي ذكرتها جورنال
كما ان القوات الروسيه سحبت ما يصل الى
20,000 فردي من قوات النخبه بامان في خطوه
منها لاعاده الانتشار ونقلها الى جهه اخرى
بالقرب من مدينه خرسون للتحضر لمعركه اخرى
وفي المقابل العسكريون الاوكرانيون يرون
ان المعركه الصعبه ستكون خارج صفاته وهي
مدينه على اطراف خرسون والذي توجد فيها
نخبه من القوات الخاصه الروسيه تختلط
بالقوات التي تم تعبئتها حديثا بحسب
واشنطن بوست كما ان هؤلاء الجنود تدعمهم
طائرات استطلاع بدون طيار الاستهداف
القوات الاوكرانيه التي تحاول التقدم
زياده اعداد القوات الروسيه في خرسون
جنوبا ودوم باز شرقا قد يحد من قدرتها على
الهجوم في مواقع اخرى
كما ان هذا التقدم الاخير للقوات
الاوكرانيه قد يمكنها من استهداف خطوط
الامداد الروسيه التي تصل الى شبه جزيره
القرم التي ضمتها روسيا في عام 2014 خطوط
الامداد هذه تشكل اهميه قصوى لروسيا
خصوصا وان قواعدها العسكريه في شبه جزيره
القرم يعتمدون على الامدادات والمياه
العذبه من البر الرئيس الاوكراني التي تمر
عبر الاراضي التي تسيطر عليها الان
وبسبب هذه الاهميه قامت روسيا بالاستعداد
مسبقا في حاله حدوث في اي اختراق من
القوات الاوكرانيه
وذلك من خلال حفل خنادق بالقرب من حدود
شبه جزيره القرمودومباس اي على بعد 40
ميلا تقريبا خلف الخطوط الاماميه بحسب
تقرير نشرته وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
لصحيفه جورنال
بالاضافه الى هذا الموقع المهم الذي
تستهدفه القوات الاوكرانيه فهناك الجسر
البري الذي يمتد غربا من روسيا الى دينمو
والذي تحاول كيف من خلاله قطعه هذا الرابط
الروسي الحيوي من خلال التركيز على فك
الحصار عن زموريج المحاصره التي من شانها
ان تقطع السبل بالقوات الروسيه الى الغرب
وتعزل القوات في شبه جزيره القرم سلطان
العربيه